le risque à mon avis serait là oui qu'on
se conçoit dans une sur censure parce
que il n'ya pas il y aurait beaucoup de
signalements et que le nombre de
signalements à un moment attirerait
l'attention du service juridique de
l'accord exxon twitter de twitter en
l'occurrence et qu' ils vont dire dans
le doute
comme on a beaucoup de signal on enlève
tout et on verra après c'est le
véritable problème c'est aussi de cette
fois c'est le renforcement du pouvoir
économique des grandes plateformes c'est
que elle elle ont les moyens aujourd'hui
de concevoir des algorithmes avec des
bases de données va se donner deux mots
contextualiser de mots tout court mais
aussi d'image qui systématiquement vont
être utilisés par leur système dit de
modération qui vont faire que ils vont
avoir une avance technologique par
rapport à des nouveaux entrants qui font
qu'à l'arrivée il pourrait tuer toute la
concurrence dire que cette loi peut leur
donner un pouvoir économique
supplémentaire ce qui pose ce qui pose
un souci c'est pour ça qu'on a plusieurs
on avait tenté et on là dessus on
s'était appuyé aussi sur les travaux qui
avaient mené la quadrature sur la
question de l'interopérabilité
il y à des réseaux alternatifs
mastodonte en est on est un exemple ou
des personnes qui étaient sur les
réseaux classiques se sentant harceler
sont sortis des réseaux classiques ont
créé leur propre système collaboratif
avec des règles qu'ils se sont fixés
avec une modération qui l'ont qu'ils
organisent eux-mêmes ils peuvent en
sortir sans perdre leurs contacts et
aujourd'hui la véritable difficulté
c'est le pouvoir économique de facebook
et twitter quand vous sortez de facebook
et twitter vous perdez tous vos contacts
vous perdez la capacité de communiquer
avec ces personnes là est une forme de
censure et aussi pour rassemble deux
personnes de restreindre leur compte
twitter
on va le voir mais moi je léger
l'exemple en vendée d'un élu qui se
représente qui a coupé l'accès à son
compte twitter pour éviter que des
listes concurrentes puisse avoir des
informations réagir aux informations
qu'ils publiaient voilà et aujourd'hui
on parle de ça le texte de laëtitia via
il parle aussi de ça il parle de comment
est ce qu'on va faire sur les réseaux
sociaux pour avoir accès à de
l'information pour la coupe et pour
éventuellement contre ce reconsidérons
seront conférer un pouvoir économique et
c'est ça qui me gêne aussi dans ce texte
là au delà de la sueur censure
[Musique]